okay you're ready to play a game first  of all I do have a date with George for  these twins are you gonna go out and  have a good time with them yes I have he  climbs the mole and I had been talking  she's not returning my emails but I'm  talking about twins in the celebrity  world okay we're gonna need some twins  and you're gonna guess who the parents  are okay  gonna help okay Phineas Walter and hazel  Patricia Julia Roberts Emma and Max Oh  Jennifer Lopez  Mariana Tabitha sir Jessica yes Mateo  and Valentino one more time with pay yo  and Tino oh hey I tried Vivian and not  he'll Angelina Jolie we had the same  doctor no big deal  really we ask questions about babies  every question